[Music]
welcome
to the week in 60 minutes brought to you
by spectator tv
recorded on thursday march the 17th
on this week's show the government is
seeking to renew its emergency pandemic
powers
but where's the emergency i'll be
speaking to former supreme court judge
jonathan consumption and where's the
opposition
the spectator's political team will
analyze the many troubles of labour
party leader
kyo starmer we'll also talk irish
travelers
are they still being discriminated
against and former brexit secretary
david davis will join us to talk about
his commons intervention in the ongoing
surgeon
salmon civil war all that to come in the
next hour
of top analysis and debate as always if
you subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel
then why would you it's free you'll
never miss a program
just click the subscribe button at the
bottom right of the screen now
a very special thanks to charles stanley
for their continued support of the week
in 60 minutes
charles stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms
one of the oldest companies on the
london stock exchange we're delighted
to be partners with them now next week
the government will seek to renew its
emergency covert powers
for another six months even though the
vaccine rollout continues on target
hospitalizations and deaths are
collapsing and in three months
the final covered restrictions are
expected to go in england
so why the need for emergency powers
through to the autumn
i'll be speaking shortly to jonathan
sumption but first
let's go to kate andrews our economics
correspondent she edits the spectators
daily lunchtime briefing which contains
all that you need to know
about each day's latest covert news kate
over to you thanks andrew as you say
mps are set to debate and extend the
emergency powers before the easter break
and this has prompted a deep dive into
the data to look at how we're really
tackling covet 19 in the uk at the
moment
as you can see from this first slide the
seven day average for infections has
been on a steady decline
now sitting around where infections were
in early to mid september last year
and here in the second slide you can see
that hospitalizations
are on an even steeper decline and this
is looking at the number of patients
admitted to hospital
which is now down to where it was in
early october
and this has certainly been helped by
the vaccine rollout which is preventing
not just against catching covid19 but of
course serious reactions to the virus
which can lead to hospitalization and
sadly death
although if we look at this third chart
here deaths again clearly
in a steady decline as well with the
seven day average now reflecting where
we were in early to mid october last
year
as well now sadly this is not the story
that is reflected
everywhere else the uk as you can see
from this next chart
has one of the lowest case rates in
europe this week italy put
much of the country back into red zones
a very restrictive form of lockdown as
another wave hits
france is expected to extend lockdown
measures into the paris region in the
days to come
and the czech republic has even been
relying on hospi on the hospital
capacity of other countries
to treat their patients now much of what
is behind this
is europe's struggle with their vaccine
rollout
and you can see from this last slide
that the uk continues not just to be a
leader in europe
but a leader worldwide when it comes to
this jab race
there were worrying indications
yesterday that we may be looking at a
slowdown
of our vaccine rate in in the month
ahead a reminder that the story is far
from over
but when we're debating the
extraordinary government powers
you can see how one could certainly make
the case that parts of europe
are experiencing a state of emergency
but that argument is becoming much more
difficult to make here in the uk
at least right now back to you andrew
thanks kate it's kind of a striking
graph there of uh
between britain and the rest of the
other european
union countries up tell us a bit more if
you can about this uh astro
zenica vaccine shortage if it is a
vaccine shortage
some sort of scale stories in the london
papers this morning
i think in short andrew yes it is a bit
worrying we got this leaked letter
yesterday from nhs
england to local vaccine suppliers
saying that they were expecting supply
to be more
limited in the month ahead and it's
thought that part of the reason for this
is a delay in getting roughly five
million doses of astrazeneca
from india that there's been a delay on
the export
from india and which is disappointing
news especially for those who haven't
had their first job
yet because in this letter it states
that there should be
a pause on offering people appointments
to get their first job although it's
insistent if you've had your first job
you shouldn't worry your second one is
still coming now ministers have been
quick to say that this is just part of
the process that
the vaccine rollout is going to have its
peaks and troughs and people shouldn't
be worried
and they're also insistent that their
deadlines are they're sticking to when
it comes to
the top nine most vulnerable categories
of people being inoculated by the 15th
of april
and then for all adults to have gotten
their first job by the end of july but i
do think this is an important reminder
that while things are going so well and
as you saw in that
chart about the vaccine race the uk
really is a world leader
the race is not over we're still going
and there's still many hurdles that we
have to
overcome so unfortunately it looks like
there could be a bit of a slowdown in
april
but other vaccines are expected to come
online in the spring we don't have
specific details yet but we should be
looking at the moderna vaccine
hopefully in the near future so things
could pick up as well
well there are a lot of european
countries sitting on a huge batch of
astrozenica that they say they don't
want to use
because they think it doesn't work very
well can we not just get them
to send over the stuff they don't want
yeah this is becoming a bit of a circus
in the european union for months now you
have had ursula van der lion and you've
had
major european leaders undermining
confidence in the astrazeneca vaccine
and indeed in the uk's rollout of
vaccines full stop suggesting that
our nimble regulator perhaps skipped
over some safety precautions for which
there is
absolutely no evidence you had germany
you had france suggesting i think it was
macron said that the
vaccine was quasi-effective for the over
65s again
no evidence for this and now we're in a
very strange strange
position um where many of these eu
countries are on the one hand
complaining that
astrazeneca hasn't been giving them the
supplies that were promised
and they're in a rage about this and
then on the other hand uh suggesting
that they have to pause this vaccine
because they're not sure
about the safety standards what i would
say in defense of the eu
is that the european medicines agency is
adamant that this vaccine is safe and
that it should be administered
to all of the adult age groups and
they're pleading with
european countries to start up the roll
out of astrazeneca again if it's been
paused so
in many cases it's not the eu although
there have been moments i think from
from leaders in the eu that have
undermined this process
but individual european leaders and it's
frustrating because
it seems political in many of these
circumstances it
it just seems like they're following
they're getting in line
following one after the next following
what their neighbors are doing but it
isn't necessarily in the best interest
of the nations
the problem is that even if the european
medical authorities say it's okay
and everybody expects that that's
exactly what they're going to do
i'm afraid chancellor merkel and
president macron have poisoned the well
uh opinion polls in france for example
show that there's a substantial
minority of uh french people who just
won't take astrazeneca
uh now i mean they they will not find
this easy kate to roll back
uh they they have uh already changed
public opinion and public opinion won't
dance to their tune now i think it's a
as europe is hit by a third wave as your
figures show
this is a real crisis for europe i would
suggest i fear deeply andrew that people
who are vulnerable to this virus people
who could end up in hospitalization
even sadly end up dead from this virus
may be put off getting the vaccine
because of what these major european
leaders have said i think you're right
it's very hard to roll back now because
it's not the first instance that they've
done it they've been doing it for months
now and whereas we're talking about how
to get out of lockdown
all the talk in the major european
countries
is going back into lockdown italy has
already done it
uh president macron has defied his
experts so far
but is now under huge pressure to have a
third lockdown
my own view is that by the weekend the
ill defaults is essentially the greater
paris region that will be in lockdown
and perhaps the hall of deforms too up
around
calais and the northeast of france as
well
and it seems that if you haven't
vaccinated enough of your population
and you are faced with this third wave
then you go back into lockdown that's
what europe is facing with all that now
means
for delaying economic recovery and
getting people back
to work that's what what i mean by this
being a fool
for for me this seems kate to be the
biggest crisis of europe
since the eurozone crisis way back in
2013. well andrea i think you're right
because
all of the principles that they held and
also the practicalities the things that
are supposed to be benefits of being in
the european union seem to be
falling apart and a lot of that
horrendously has come down to the
attitudes the political attitudes of
leaders towards getting their nations
vaccinated
and i would note that the uk is still in
one of the strictest lockdowns in the
developed world even though
europe as the slideshow is facing more
of the crisis at the moment
the uk government is being extremely
cautious about coming out of lockdown so
when we talk about europe going back in
they're going to be facing some measures
that we're already living under
here in the uk um so i think the the the
lockdown
point is actually a very interesting one
because you have countries that are in a
far
greater state of emergency than the uk
and yet the uk is in this very strict
lockdown and is set to be
under lockdown measures for months to
come can you give
any possible explanation as to why
the european commission wants to ban the
export of astrazeneca or
threatening to ban the export of the
astrozenica
vaccine while at the same time
saying it doesn't want to use astrovenic
zenica i mean that just i i just don't
understand the logic of that
well i think um you're seeing
desperation i mean
when a supposedly free market block
starts talking about
um seizing private assets private
materials like vaccines
essentially um to use for their own
people when they're undermining contract
law in that way
you have to chalk that up to absolute
desperation and but this is where you
are seeing a divide i think between
the commission and individual eu
countries because as i said that the
european medicines agency is insistent
that this vaccine is safe and that it
works
for all adult age categories and they're
very hopeful i think
that some of these other eu countries
major eu countries that have a lot of
soft power influence
will change their minds in the near
future and start using it again so i
imagine they're hopeful
that if they have the supply it will be
rolled out but as you say andrew so much
has been done to
undermine the credibility of this
vaccine in the eu
um it's very difficult to see how they
just reverse that overnight
it is indeed we'll need to keep an eye
on this cape thank you
for joining us kate andrews there our
economics uh correspondent there's a lot
going on in
europe at the moment a lot of its
politics rather than science
the chancellor merkel uh her party was
thumped into major
regional elections just the last weekend
there there is a
widespread talk in germany now that the
ce cdu
may not farm form part of the german
government
after the federal elections in september
there is a crisis now
in chancellor america's cdu and
president macron
uh the latest polls show that he is now
nip and tuck with marine le pen
of the hard right national front uh both
around 50
48 to 52 so there are major problems
going on there meanwhile
we learn that half a trillion dollars
left the eurozone region
uh in the fourth quarter of 2020
before the whole vaccine mess
clicked in and there is widespread
expectation in financial circles that a
lot more than half a trillion
dollars will leave the eurozone in the
first quarter of this year it's
beginning to look a little bit more
like capital flight is beginning to take
place from the eurozone
anyway one man who's been vocal on this
side of the channel
uh in his criticism of the government's
approach is jonathan assumption
he's a former supreme court judge he
joins us now
uh jonathan welcome to spectator tv
morning um do you not have any sympathy
with the government on its slow approach
to coming out of
the lockdown which you could defend as a
a better safe than sorry approach well
the government's position throughout
right from
last march has been that it will not
discriminate
between people according to their
different levels of vulnerability
so it has locked down healthy people
and young people who are at very small
risk of getting
seriously ill let alone dying and it has
adhered to that
throughout what we are seeing now is
that
an even bigger anomaly about this
approach because with
more than a third of the population
vaccinated including
a very high proportion of all the most
vulnerable people
they are still saying that everybody has
got to be
treated in exactly the same way whether
they are vulnerable to this disease
or not i think we are now reaching the
stage
when people are going to start losing
patients with this
it's clear that there is a third wave
about
we see that most of all in continental
europe because their vaccine rollout has
been slow
is going to hit them worse hit britain
less because
of the success so far of our vaccine
program
in the circumstances we now find
ourselves in
what would you like the government to do
going forward into spring and early
summer
i think that they should now recognize
that it
is a lot more efficient and effective
for each of us to make our own
risk assessments because our positions
are too different to allow
for anything else some of us have had
the disease but already
some of us have been vaccinated some of
us are young
some old some healthy some not a
one-size-fits-all approach
is no longer a defensible way of
approaching this
we have got to make a risk assessment
for ourselves and those
immediately around us what would happen
if that then
led to a huge spike in cases
and deaths i think that it's unlikely to
lead to a huge spike
i would certainly accept that it might
lead to a small one
but we have to be prepared to take risks
because of the enormous collateral
costs if even if you simply confine
yourself to the position of the
of of the health sector we are looking
at a significant increase in diseases
like dementia and cancer which are also
killers
but actually this isn't just a public
health issue
it's an economic issue it's a moral
issue it's an educational issue it's a
social issue
we've got to face the fact that it may
be worth putting up
with a modest increase in the death toll
in order to be able to have an economy
that functions
an educational system that functions we
simply
have to accept that no country ever
saved lives by making itself poorer
the government though is very influenced
i would suggest by what happened
last summer and into early autumn
by last summer we thought things were
going to open out and we had that eat
out scheme where you were
subsidized go to the local restaurant
things seemed to be beginning to get
back to normal the economy was beginning
to pick up too and then suddenly cases
started
to rise again and death started to rise
again
and the government delayed bringing in
more lockdown
uh procedures then and it's being
accused now
as a result of that increasing deaths
because it was so
slow to act to move in to further
lockdown
isn't that isn't it right that the
government should
take notice of its previous experience
when it didn't go so well
of course but we have to look rather
carefully at what its previous
experience was
right from the outset indeed in the
notorious imperial college statistical
projection produced in the middle of
march
last year the government was told that
lockdowns
only work if they are kept in place
permanently
until there's a vaccine so actually the
government had a choice
it could say at last march we will now
have
a vaccine a lockdown that will last for
as long as it takes
to get the vaccine or it might as well
forget the lockdown altogether
because the reality is as the imperial
college study
quite clearly showed is that if you have
a lockdown
and then lift it what happens is that
the lives that you've saved
during the lockdown the deaths are
simply shunted
into a later period now i doubt whether
the british people
even in their relatively submissive mood
of last year would have tolerated
the government saying we are going to
lock you all down
for what may be anything up to 18 months
or at least a year
but that was the choice that they had
the reality is
that if more people who were young and
healthy
had got the disease during the summer
when they were most unlikely these are
categories that are most unlikely to
become seriously ill or die
many more of them would have had a
natural immunity
at the time when the more virulent
strains came in
during the autumn i don't think it's at
all clear
that this policy worked
when the lockdown was in force i don't
think it's at all clear
that if the lockdown had been kept
permanently in place
it would have been complied with the
fact is a lockdown can work
if it is one total and two
indefinite in duration and that would
have done even more
catastrophic damage to our educational
sector
and our economy and to the health of
people
in respect of other diseases than what
we've suffered anyway
and yet the british government is not
alone
in not following your advice when it
comes to lockdown
almost every major government in the
democratic world
has been forced into lockdowns
various forms of them politicians
governments are very difficult different
political hues
whether it's governor cuomo in new york
or president macron
in france or chancellor merkel in
germany or whoever
was prime minister back then i can't
remember that it's now
mr draghi but back then whoever was
prime minister in italy
they had to do lockdowns too
particularly in the north uh i mean
there has to be something to the
argument that if all these governments
saw that was the right way
there has to be something in that only
if they were
making an independent judgment in fact
what was happening
is that they were all copying each other
because they were afraid that their own
populations would say oh look
in the country next door they're doing
this why aren't you doing something
similar
the fact is that before the lockdowns
were ordered
all governments that had done serious
studies about this
including our own had a policy based on
serious scientific advice that they
would not lock people down
you can take our example for example and
i'll mention germany in a moment
in this country we had been planning for
an event exactly like this
for more than 10 years it was top of the
national risk register
in 2011 a detailed plan which was kept
regularly up to date was prepared as to
how to deal with it
and the basic principles behind that
plan
were first of all that you did not use
coercion
you used advice to the population
but you allowed them to make their own
risk assessments
and secondly that you did not isolate
or take abrasive measures against the
healthy you concentrated
on isolating the infectious and the sick
now strikingly enough exactly the same
principles lay behind the german
national pandemic plan which was drawn
up
by the robert koch institute which is a
highly respected body
they all those that have published plans
worked along exactly the same lines and
the world health organization
also recommended exactly that approach
so what we have here is governments
independently
forming the view that they should take a
less abrasive attitude to major
pandemics
and then all copying each other and
throwing out the window
10 years worth of careful scientific and
administrative planning
that does not do credit to any of these
governments
they basically jettisoned their own
research
now i've heard it said that nobody
expected
that there would be any pandemic
anything like as serious as this
i'm afraid that is simply untrue the
2017 edition of the national risk
register in this country
envisaged that a new pathogen might
cause
deaths up to 750 000 not even professor
ferguson
has suggested that the deaths would have
been anything like that on any of the
various hypotheses
so what we have actually done is to
reject the scientific approach
to adopt a policy that fails to
discriminate
between different degrees of
vulnerability and that is scientifically
disreputable
the reason why this is happening is the
fear of populations across europe
and their belief that if their
governments are not doing something
abrasive and hyperactive about it
they are going to sleep on the job
that's never been true
they they had very careful plans and
they should have adhered to them
a final question for you do you see a
link as some do
a link between a government that has now
presided over
a variety of lockdowns for a year now
and this new policing bill which would
seem
to in various ways crib and confine
our ability to protest and demonstrate
peacefully
um i don't see much of a link i think
there's a good deal of
of press reporting to suggest and it
sounds plausible
that the home secretary was much
exercised by protests against the
lockdown and
if that is true then it may well be that
there is a link but actually the issues
raised
uh in the current bill have been around
for a long time parts of the bill
are perfectly acceptable in my view and
parts of it
are not the bits that aren't acceptable
are the bits that give an altogether
excessive discretion
to both the police and the home
secretary we ought not to have laws that
are defined entirely by the home
secretary
who is now under this bill it's proposed
to give her powers
to say it's to say what constitutes
sufficient disruption to constitute a
criminal offence
we ought not to allow policemen on the
hoof
to decide which protests they will
curtail and which
they will not on the other hand other
parts of the bill
are perfectly respectable because it
seems to me that a person's right to
protest stops
short at the point when they have to
trample on other people's rights to go
about their ordinary business
and the creation of a a public nuisance
offence
seems to me to be a desirable and
healthy step
john consumption uh thank you for that
thank you for joining us on spectator tv
pleasure now politics uh this week's
spectator cover story written by our
political editor james forsyth takes a
look at just why
kyocera's labor leadership has been so
well lackluster i guess is the polite
way of doing it
uh let's go straight to james james why
is zakir sahama struggling
because i think kirsten essentially made
a bet
that oppositions don't open elections
governments lose them
and so his whole argument against the
government was based around
competence and you know last november
that that seemed to be paying off labor
had drawn level in the polls with the
conservatives
but the vaccine rollout has shifted
things around given the government a
boost
and labour are now trailing um and
and i think the other quest point is
that people don't know what kierstama
stands for i think he's begun to get the
message out but he's not jeremy corbyn
but what what is stammerism is still a
question that leaves most voters
scratching their heads
let's bring in katie balls the
spectator's deputy political editor
she's been listening to
james there she's also written part of
the the song what we call the sidebar
on this week's cover story hey katie you
say that uh
kyostarma is playing a long game
what does that mean what's what's the
long game i think what it means
is i think that could be a charitable
interpretation in terms of the long game
but i think what this ultimately means
is if you look to when the next election
is going to be
so the fact it could be a couple of
years away definitely
even if it is 2020 free as some people
are talking about
that's a long time and i think what the
leaders offers believe
is that they have so much to fix from
the jeremy corbyn legacy
that actually they need to focus on
party management before they get to the
point that they're really making the
case to the public
but i think adding to that the pandemic
now lots of people would say
with a death toll over 100 000 and
really one of the worst economic
performances in europe there's lots
to attack the government on but what you
frequently hear from shadow cabinet
members
as well as various aides is that
pandemic politics is much harder
and in all their focus groups they just
hear that voters want the government to
succeed and they don't want labour
opportunistic and that is creating a
problem whereby they don't think they
actually can attack the government as
they want to
could be james of course the long game
is very long
i mean after the disaster is for labor
winter of discontent in
1979 they were not back in power
until 1997
and after the pretty lackluster years of
john major
who lost to mr blair in 1997 the tories
weren't back in part of 2010
and that it had to be in coalition with
the lib dams
we may have underestimated the huge
damage
uh generational damage perhaps that
jeremy corbyn has done to the labour
party
yeah i think one of the other problems
for labour is that at the next election
you'd afford labour be able to say the
tories have been in power for 14 years
and
as you were just just articulating you
know once a party's been in power for
that long
you can lay every single problem at
their door
and say if they haven't fixed it already
they're not going to
i think one of the challenges for labor
is
that uh because of covert and the
pandemic
i think the tory argument is in the next
election will be
we're three or four years into a kind of
rebuilding plan a recovery plan
post covered and so we need time to
finish the job
and so i think you know the stories are
going for a fifth term which is
unprecedented in british poll
in recent modern british political
history but some of that time for a
change argument for labor is going to be
blunted
by the fact that the government will be
talking about how you know they are
four years into their ten year
rebuilding plan
casey one area where you would think
traditionally labor
particularly the the civil uh human
rights
element of the labor party would have
been up in arms is over the the police
bill that i was talking to lord
assumption
about there uh that's i would have
thought something that labor really
could get its
teeth into and of course the
demonstrations uh
around the death of sarah everhart as
well
would give them some locus on that but
they seem very reluctant to take the
government on in this subject
yes completely and they only made the
decision to really oppose that and offer
opposition after what happened at the
weekend at the sarah everard vigil
but even without that you would have
thought this is something where labour
might be able to find their voice
and i think this is where you see
kirsten slightly torn because on the one
hand
if particularly he look at his track
record you would think uh individual
liberties would be something that
kirsten want to push for particularly if
that means
protest groups that have been overlooked
but on the other uh
the thing the leader's office really
wants to do is as one put it to me
make sure people don't think we're mad
and part of that is this idea that
kirsten is a patriot
and labor can be trusted with law and
order and i think almost that latter
concern about trying to show that this
is a respectable party
and actually on things like the police
labour where they should be
is holding them back on things that
would actually be labor values
james the it could be it's simply
mission impossible for kia starman
that it's just the times that we are in
the government
mr johnson has had a huge bounce because
of the success
of the vaccine rollout let's assume
that continues there's a halo effect on
that
that takes the government into 2022
the office for budget responsibility is
predicting seven percent plus
growth in 2022 huge
job creation rising living standards um
it could be more than seven percent uh
but i see the fed
has updated its forecast for the united
states and we're in roughly a similar
position coming out of the the recovery
so you've got this massive economic
growth um household spending money again
in 2022 that takes you into 2023
why not call a snap or an election
either in late spring or early autumn of
2023
which is things look at now it doesn't
matter what kills the armor does the
tories will probably win that
yeah look i think it is very challenging
for him but i also think
that the other point from kiera starman
the duke of wellington said there's only
uh one thing half as melancholy as a
battle lost and that's a battle one
and i think when the smoke clears and we
see the economic situation post code
it won't look quite so rosy there will
undoubtedly be an increase in
private sector unemployment uh there'll
be huge backlogs in the nhs
uh in the court system uh there'll be
lost
learning in education and the government
will be worried about inflation and what
that might do to the cost of servicing
the government
the national debt so it won't be able to
kind of throw money at every problem in
the way that joe biden is doing in the
us
so i think there is actually there i
think that you you painted one very
plausible scenario there is a more
favorable scenario to labor coming out
where all of the problems post covert
become apparent
and because the government has been in
power and took the decisions it can't
get away from
from them and labour can attack them on
that so that's opportunity
i think the other challenge for labour
is scotland it's very hard to see how
labour can win a majority without a
revival in scotland now in alaska they
have a new more impressive
scottish labour leader than they've had
in some time but i think that's a real
problem for them because
even if the tories and labour were close
in the polls going into the next
election
that would raise the whole question as
to whether later would be prepared to do
a deal
with the snp to govern at westminster
and
one thing we have discovered in the last
few elections is that that association
is particularly toxic
in the minds of english and welsh voters
katie final question on this segment
uh to you uh it could be that kyocerma
is a decent man
doing the best he can in very difficult
circumstances
given what he inherited from the corbyn
labour party
and i would suggest and i know you've
been speaking to a number of them so you
know better than me
it isn't just a problem if there is a
problem with the labor leadership
it's a problem with his shadow cabinet
too i mean how can i be
polite about the shadow cabinet i mean
it's up against a cabinet that's not
exactly a
five-star uh johnson cabinet
but the shadow cabinet itself is
distinctly
underwhelming yes i think most people
don't really know who is in the shadow
cabinet
i think probably one of the biggest
names ed miliband and i think if you
said a few years ago that that would be
labour's star player after the
general election and people would have
been slightly surprised or bewildered
and i think that there are problems
there i think that
there are lots of labour mps who want to
tell you there are problems there and
there has to be a shared cabinet
reshuffle that's partly because they
want to be in that and
and to get positions um but there is a
problem with cut through now
what you will hear is the defense is in
a pandemic it's very hard to get cut
through but of course
joe biden managed to win an election in
a pandemic
i think in terms of the shadow cabinet
the one to watch is annalise dodds
because
i think of all the people who received
the most criticism it's the shadow
chancellor
and we recently saw in the budget uh
when it comes to the the freezing of the
various um thresholds you had a
situation where annelise does the party
was going to support that
only for a few days later lisa nandy the
shadow foreign secretary
to do a sunday morning round saying they
were going to oppose it and i think
things like that are just adding to the
sense that perhaps that
person will not be the person going to
bat for the party
in the treasury in the next election
right can you believe it
i think you said it all when you said
that ed miliband was the best known of
the shadow cabinet
members i think there's no more to say
after you said that
james and kenny thanks for joining us
today now holidays beckon post lockdown
this summer but with
unvaccinated europe in the grip of a
covert third wave the
costa del sol or the french riviera
might be a gamble
so why not a windswept british holiday
camp like
pontons none of you have an irish name
it decided they were not to be welcomed
in an apartment attempt
to keep out irish travelers it's a
bizarre story
joining me is one would-be victim of
ponton's baffling band
melanie mcdonough who writes about the
band in this week's issue melanie
welcome to
spectator tv have you managed to
establish
what thought process what decision take
taking process
ever led pontons to take this decision
in the first place
well i don't think it's um terribly
difficult to work it out
i mean um they were looking for um
travel
traveler names but um you do need to be
exceptionally sophisticated perhaps even
more so than ponton's
management to be able to work out the
most common traveler names
and to try and distinguish them from the
general irish population
the the list included it excluded
funnily enough the o'neills
who obviously um featured largely in the
in northern ireland
but um it did happen a troublesome bunch
there were very troublesome bubbles
very bad reputation yes they should have
been barred as well
but um the mcdonald's are one of the
very few names that are actually
um very specifically uh travelers so um
when you hear the surname mcdonald's the
automatic association is with them
is with the thinkers um and i'm sure
that that was what
pundits were trying to do in their um
instruction to the employees at the um
reception um they did suggest that if
they have any trouble to try and
get hold of somebody from management
who'd be able to listen into the
conversation and decide whether the
person was going to be barred
and in that case you're relying on
another
uh signaller which is the distinctive
diction
of travelers or tinkers because the way
the community talks is slightly
different from that of um
other irish people so it does require a
very
keen sort of social antenna and there's
very specific knowledge
of place names in relation to places for
them
actually to pinpoint travelers and this
list of 40 names
manages to alienate practically every um
irish person in britain because it's
extraordinarily comprehensive
and as i mentioned in the piece um that
would be c of mark carney
the former governor of the bank of
england and also
uh terence leahy the former um the head
of tescos
so um tragically they won't be going to
pontons either no
though um i don't think it's a huge loss
for them i didn't
quite think that governor carney would
have ponton's high up in his uh
holiday wish list but they really didn't
see
that there's a difference between irish
names and travelers
they didn't it didn't dawn on them
well it seems not um it is actually
very difficult because in different
parts of the country you will have
different names associated with
travellers as i say in the west of
ireland
um that mcdonough's are a very um
substantial traveler group but um in
other parts of the country it might be
ward in other parts of the country it
might be lynch
so they're treading um on very
difficult territory there in trying to
make the distinction which of course
they shouldn't be making in the first
place
does does pontins have a a track record
of a bad experience with travelers is it
has it had travelers on holiday there
and that hasn't worked out too well is
there anything they've been
very shy about um explaining their
motivation for some reason that escapes
me
but one would assume that yes this is
the case but it may well be just the
generic
discrimination that travelers get from
everyone i mean in ireland
um it's exactly the same they're
excluded from
entertainment venues and from pubs and
um from pretty well anywhere where
there might be a gathering um there's
one um the irish comedian
um who's actually um uniquely and
a stand-up comedian who's a traveller
and he was saying whenever he tries to
book a venue
and or his agent tries to book a venue
everywhere is booked up until 2027
because nobody actually wants them
because they think that um travelers
will
join the audience and have a fight
in fact he said the only people who were
remotely rowdy during his
gigs were people from the settle
community
and the travelers will model um the
members of the audience
is it this is surely
against all the human rights laws and
the equalities act
well indeed um you have to worry about
them
really because um only an idiot would
have actually written it down
and but
as i say um the practice if not the um
the listing is um extraordinarily
widespread
and um you're going to find it in
ireland as well as in britain
but the equalities and human rights
commission did have a quiet word of them
and they said that they'd they'd take
note of the observations and they'd be
amending their practice
oh so they've they've rolled back a bit
melanie
yeah they might roll back a bit so i
might i might be in with a chance
you yeah you may be it's worth whether
he's calling we could take the call
and uh see how they they handle you in
fact we could both uh try and get
i can go with o'neill let's see what uh
see what they
say yes you try for your deals and i'll
try for the mcdonald's and see how we
get on
i'm surprised that there hasn't been a
far bigger corporate backlash against uh
pontins uh it's um it's clear that even
the
human rights uh campaigners don't give
much
uh credence to uh travelers problems
it's just as well
i could imagine the outcry be rather
different that fountain said it was
banning old jamaican names
oh my goodness um yeah it doesn't bear
thinking about i mean there'd be war
but um this kind of is um symptomatic of
the
condition of the travelers generally
because there was a
report recently by the european union's
fundamental
rights agency which said that
an extraordinary number of travelers
just experienced routine discrimination
i mean in six different countries in the
eu
but over half of them said they never
dream of
reporting it to the police because they
just don't think that anything would
happen
and it's so routine harassment and
and abuse and discrimination that um
they just think well why bother
talking about it all right we'll leave
it there i'm sure there's a
few corporate meetings going on at
ponton's to work out how to get out of
this mess melanie thank you for marking
our card
on it it's a strange story indeed
melanie mcdonald not
not banned from spectator tv but could
have trouble
getting into practice she so desired it
now
our final segment scotland uh the former
brexit secretary david davis made a
significant intervention
in the commons this week invoking
parliamentary privilege he revealed
new information passed on to him by a
whistleblower on the salmon sturgeon
stromash the scottish word that in
scotland
casting yet more doubt on nicola
sturgeon's version of events
he joins me now together with fraser
nelson the editor
of the spectator another scot uh which
this week carries a powerful editorial
on
the matter welcome to you both david
davis first why did you decide to get
involved
well sort of two things were happening
in parallel um
firstly you had the two trials that
that alex hammond went through i mean
the the civil
trial which he won by a spectacular
margin you know punitive cost given and
so on
and the other one um the criminal trial
now whenever
somebody you're friendly with goes on
trial i always suspend my judgment for
the duration i try not to
come to a view either way uh but again
despite 14 charges it exonerated all of
them i thought this is this is
something odds going on here so i
started to pay attention to it that was
the sort of first half
but the other thing is watching the
behavior of the scottish government i
mean your
paper is about the spectator and you in
fact you wrote in the
daily mail on it and so on so all of
those things came together and i started
to look at it and
ask around and see what was going on and
so on and then i got sent
uh a a package of papers which was the
surrounding texts and i started on pick
it all and it
became clear to me that something was
wrong in the state of scotland basically
what i'm uncertain about in this
interview is is
what you can talk about that you talked
about in parliament covered by privilege
and what you can't talk about
because you're not now covered by
privilege and neither is spectator tv
do you have a clear idea what you can
say to us today
up to a point but look one of the one of
the thing interesting things has been
happening in scotland
is the behavior of the crown office
right and
the uh crown officer in my view has been
stretching it even in scottish law has
been stretching its powers
to the limit asserting to um
everybody from journalists to salmons
lawyers
to the uh to the holyrood committee that
they can't publish this they can't
summon that they can't do
this or that actually things properly
done by a court not by a prosecuting
authority remember
they look at the equivalent of the cps
in england they're they're not a court
and just before i came on air here i had
a call from a journalist
uh saying oh the crown office is going
to be looking into where you got all
this information
you know to which i'm afraid my response
was
tell them to go back and read their law
books about parliamentary privilege you
know
but it's there are grey areas in it much
of what i
said in the chamber was
uh already public domain i mean kenny
mccaskill's put some stuff in the public
domain
um xxx uh justice secretary
um so it's it's it's uh some of it's at
the margin some of the
some of the uh um the the text messages
were new
and some of the some of the emails were
new
they may well fall within privilege um
and so i'm going to stay off them but
quite a good chunk of it was actually
perfectly possible
to do publicly but had never been done
and never you know so for some reason
scotland nobody
laid out the the sort of narrative of
the three
great problems the problem of how they
first investigated salmon was that fair
the problem of how they behaved with the
with the judicial review
and the problem eventually of the way
the crown office and the government the
scottish government generally
have seek sought to sort of shut down
the review
shut down the access to information
break it up into small pieces
make it more complicated it needs to be
so it's actually very difficult even for
even for scots following a day by day
basis to understand it all
so uh the answer is your question is i'm
not entirely sure
but i'm going to be quite careful in
answering your questions today
well let me approach two things because
there are two major issues here
one is did nicola sturgeon mislead
parliament about what did she know
and when did she know about the in the
internal
scottish government investigation into
alex salmon the second is mr salmon's
claim that there was a wider conspiracy
to do him down
so let me start with the first one
having reviewed the evidence and looked
at the emails
uh and seen what you've seen
is it clear in your mind that nicola
sturgeon in terms of
what did she know and when did she know
it about the complaints process
has been with the scottish parliament
and the scottish people
economical with the truth the answer is
i don't know it's pretty plain
that she knew about the salmon
uh investigation i think on the 28th
of march are you four days before her
claim date of april the second
what is much more concerning is whether
she knew much earlier than that now
the the trouble is i raised the question
i raised a a a a
an email in the house which implied that
her chief of staff
knew uh significantly earlier but it
only implied it it didn't prove it
bang to rights as it were but that email
or that
exchange of messages between the
investigating officer
and another member of the scottish civil
service about and it had to quote
um liz interference
v uh the difficult or um i forgot the
exact
phrasing now but it's in hansard um that
should have been with the inquiry
that should have been presented without
me raising it in parliament that should
have been presented
to the holyrood parliamentary inquiry
and it wasn't
and with it should have been all the
stream of messages all the stream of
electronic records
that show who judith mckinnon the
investigating officer talked to
who the chief of staff to the the first
minister talked to
really you know whether there are any
trails showing
prior knowledge that hasn't been done
yeah and in
if this were if this were a uk
parliamentary inquiry
and i were the chairman of it it would
have been done months ago
and the second uh big issue is
was there a wider conspiracy to bring
down alex salmond if it
if it couldn't bring it down from the me
to investigation could they then make it
a
criminal matter and bring them down that
way now
many people from the outside have
thought this this is the bit that's more
far-fetched that there was a conspiracy
to try and destroy him
but when you've seen the evidence you've
seen in the exchange of emails
it is possible that there was a group of
people
including civil servants within the
scottish government and
snp apparatchiks at the highest level
when you see the exchanges in the emails
that you've seen
that they were out to bring alex salmon
down do you do you agree
yeah i think i think it is possible i
think look it may be more than possible
the when when i first looked at that
aspect of it
you know alexander made a claim in front
of the inquiry a very
uh strong claim about this and there's a
piece of me that said
he's been under formidable pressure for
three years if i've been in a criminal
trial
my judgment might not be right and so i
discounted it to be honest in my head
but but when i looked at the actually
put in order the sequence of text
messages the ones that both in the
public domain and a couple
that i also revealed when i put them in
in order i
i thought actually you know this this
looks quite serious
and the the interesting thing was for me
the most interesting thing
there were references to phishing and
there were recurrent
discussions with an individual complaint
and so on but but the thing that was for
me
most persuasive was that actually within
the smp organization
itself there were concerns about what
was called supporting of witnesses you
know
um joanne cherry one of the uh who's a
qc
uh reflected that at the national
executive council of the smp
and said people in westminster were
worried about the staff members in
westminster were worried about what was
going on
and that seemed to be you know if they
thought that at that time and they knew
and they knew they would have known far
more that was in the tech than was in
the text
then there really is a strong case to
answer that was the point i made it's a
prima facie case here
there's a strong case to answer and if
that's if it is
true then it shouldn't actually be the
inquiry probably i mean if the hollywood
inquiry won't do it
it perhaps ought to be the police doing
it because it's a very very serious
uh very very serious issue you know if
in i mean i
i'm not an expert in scottish law but if
in if
if i were interfering with or talking to
or trying to persuade
a witness in a criminal inquiry whilst
the
whilst the police were actually carrying
out their inquiry
then i think i'd be breaking the law
here so
i do think it needs proper investigation
and so far it hasn't had it
all right let me bring president nelson
in now he's been listening patiently
there
is where does david davis's intervention
leave us do you think
well the difference now is that the alex
salmon story has been told in full
in the house of commons now this matters
because any other environment whether it
be
a scottish newspaper scottish parliament
even the spectator
are subject to the threats of lawyers
who can say
ah look at this you can't say this and
you can't say that and if you do we
might come after you for contempt
of court now the scottish parliament
itself um
isn't protected from these lawyers or
the house of commons is you can say
anything you like in the house of
commons and not only that
journalists can also report so the
parliamentary privilege is sort of
extended in a way
to journalists if they report on what
was said in parliament we can't be sued
for that so what we have done is taken
david davis's speech and put it word for
word
on our website so everybody can read it
now this has indeed made a difference
because it's made
it's put into the open something which
wasn't really before and that's the
extent
to which m journalists have been menaced
by the crown office and even scottish
parliamentarians
have been told they better be careful
what they say and in that way
these are these very very strange
circumstances in which we are trying to
tell one of the most explosive stories
in modern
politics but alex simond isn't just
saying that
um he thinks that he was wrong by
nicholas george and he's saying that her
allies
conspired to have him imprisoned you
don't get
allegations more explosive than that in
politics
and he might be telling the truth he
might be completely
fantasizing the only way you can decide
is if you hear what he has to say
and even here and you read his written
evidence
now we put it on our website because his
written evidence is a public
document people have got the right in a
democracy to hear what's being said
against the powerful people running that
government but
this is becoming increasingly difficult
under increasing censorship
so in intervening in the house of
commons david davis has put a lot of
things on the record
which might otherwise never have seen
the light of day
and as the scot the spectator editorial
says today that
no the lord advocate equivalent would
dare speak to the westminster parliament
in
in that that would be inconceivable
to do so but despite all the efforts of
the crime office to shut it down and to
redact and to
make very relevant information
unpublishable and to try and close the
whole
debate there are signs fraser i have
suggested this
is now having at last some cut through
uh that um that long
line of uh opinion polls showing a
majority for independence has now
ended the racist polls show independence
down the minority
and it looks like it's going to be a
much bigger struggle for nicolas
sturgeon
to get an overall majority in the may
elections than it did only a couple of
months ago
is that right i'd say so and that's
because i think the debate is slightly
changing
up until now most normal people couldn't
get their heads
around why it mattered if nicola
sturgeon said a meeting had taken place
on the second of april or the 28th
of march it seemed to be a lot of fuss
about nothing but it's becoming clearer
now but there's a new
problem a new scandal and that simply is
of snp
overreach of the emergence pretty much
of a one-party state
in scotland where it's got the majority
it's got control of the courts there's
no
separation of powers so it can get the
lawyers to menace the press
and this creates a second question does
nicola sturgeon deserve a majority if
this is how she uses it
will it be the case that the scottish
democratic system
is now being threatened by an
overpowerful government which is
overreaching
in its powers now just as theresa may
was not given a majority
in her general election people thought
yes you're better than jeremy corbyn but
you're behaving in a bit of a
power-hungry way you do not deserve a
big majority
maybe scott's beginning to think the
same about nicholas sturgeon
that yes you know you're probably a
better first minister candidate
than the rest but do you really deserve
to have majority power
when we now know and we see examples of
that power being abused
i think that's when a lot of people are
having second thoughts
meanwhile the crown office is still
trying to shut you down the crown office
still wants you to take out
or redact substantially alex salmon's uh
submission to the parliamentary inquiry
this despite the fact the spectator went
to court
the judge raised no objections to doing
it he's been up
and is still up now for many weeks
uh it kind of beggars belief the
behavior of the crime office now does it
not
it's incredible well this is alexander's
evidence has been on our website
for a couple of months now and only now
does the crown
after he gave evidence to the scottish
parliament does the crown office get in
touch saying actually
we'd like you to redact this and this
and this and this a long line of things
they'd like us to censor which do not as
they pretend
identify any complainants against
alexander but they do
contain lots of embarrassing allegations
against the behavior
of nikola sturgeon's government so now
we are being asked
to redact to censor things have been on
our website for a couple of months
and the thing is if we say no it is
absolutely unpredictable what would then
happen to us
uh the scott the crown office says we'll
be criminally liable well perhaps we
would
but then what sort of charge would we
face we've been advised we could have a
fee of about 50 000 pounds now that is a
lot of money
for a small publication like ours but it
could be more than that it could be up
to
a hundred thousand there is no cap so
what we're doing here
is we're telling our readers this is
what's happening these are the threats
that we're under
and this is the position we as a
publisher
we could probably afford to take it if a
reasonable damages but we couldn't
afford to take a six-figure fine
now if we haven't still decided what
we're going to do here but what we are
going to do is be completely transparent
with readers
every step of the way and let people
know what's going on behind the scenes
to stop
journalists reporting the story and to
stop the whole truth from coming out
david davis you your interventions had
an impact there's no question about that
it's also though raises many it almost
raises more questions that need answered
uh that have been answered so far
where do you go from here where what can
you do now
well i think the first thing i remember
that the the the
context of the debate was about what we
do
about the uh what what westminster set
up in the way
of the hollywood parliament you know we
didn't establish separation of powers
and that needs to happen in other words
a separate director of public
prosecutions
over whom nicola sturgeon or whichever
first minister has no power whatsoever
we do need to do something about the
scottish civil service which is sort of
treated as a sort of
division of the uk civil service but
without controls without checks and
balances without
ensuring it's independent and so on and
we certainly need to do something
about uh hollywood's power to hold the
government to account i mean
look scotland had uh an absolute
dominance of labor labor mps
back before devolution the early years
of devolution
now it's got an absolute dominance of of
snp mps and what we see under those
circumstances
is a serial
misuse of power it's all like the cinema
i can describe it you know
that this should not happen you know the
the uh
hollywood should not be craven in front
of
their government when when you may
remember andrew when
damien greene was arrested for
taking getting whistleblower information
it ended up
with michael martin the speaker
effectively being sacked losing his job
because he let the police into
westminster it ended up with kia stammer
then the dpp
the director of public prosecutions
having to say there's no case to answer
and it ended up with damien green being
released because
we maintain the separation of powers and
those same protections
should exist for msps and i believe that
um henry mcleish this morning came out
saying the same thing in ex-first
minister scotland
kenny mccaskill the ex-justice secretary
said and i know a number of my tory
colleagues
um north of the border both msps and mps
think it's also the case so i will argue
and i will argue to my own party you
know we should make this
a part of our manifesto that actually
any government
in scotland should actually be properly
face proper checks and balances
both in the judiciary and in the legal
sector
and also in in parliament and only that
way will you guarantee that the scots
actually get the government they deserve
the final point to you david these are
structural changes
uh which will take some time to
implement they will not affect
what is currently going on in scotland
or the current inquiry
are you minded to use parliament to
reveal
any more information that would be
helpful in the public domain
and and if the crowd office is is still
trying to redact
a chunk of mr salmon's submission would
you consider
reading these redacted parts of the
submission into the hands out record
under parliamentary privilege
well certainly if necessary because like
you i don't believe that
what their redactions i'm actually your
your uh
your readers can tell by comparing what
you've published and what the scottish
parliament is probably
what the redactions are and they're not
to protect complainants they are to
protect
uh nicola surgeon so the answer is yes
certainly i do that but the truth is it
wouldn't even be necessary
there's a way back machine in california
there's the on the internet you can go
and look
not just at your publications you can
look at the scottish parliament's
previous publications
and they won't respond to the crown
office because they they're there
to deal with sort of tin pocket ships
and authoritarian regimes who want their
information covered up they said he
won't pay any attention to scottish
crown office so
so one way or another yes and i think if
if you get forced to the position where
you have to take it down
i would be very inclined to find a
mechanism for for
uh entrenching it in hansard for all
time all right david davis thank you
that authoritarian regimes
which some mean i wish to add the
current scottish government
into that category uh david davis thank
you for joining us frasier nelson too
if there's two things that you should
read this week one is david davis's
uh speech in the commons it's all on the
spectator website
all printed word for word uh there
exactly as he delivered it and second is
the
spectator editorial on this matter it's
a powerful editorial
for press freedom and revealing the
extent to which the crown office in
scotland
is trying to close it down that's it for
this week thanks to all of our guests
and once again to our very special
sponsor
charles stanley for sponsoring the week
in 60 minutes
charles sandler is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms it's one
of the oldest firms
on the london stock exchange as always
send us any thoughts you have
to spectator tv at spectator dot co dot
uk and please join us next week
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you